merci Henri Leroy d'être avec nous
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu des Alpes-Maritimes donc du
groupe les républicains on va commencer
par l'actualité et on en a parlé c'est
cette agression du petit neveu de
Brigitte Macron agressé lundi soir après
l'intervention du chef de l'État en
marche d'une manifestation non déclarée
contre la réforme des retraites le chef
de l'État a condamné la première dame
également qui dénonce la lâcheté la
bêtise et la violence est-ce que vous
partagez ces mots tout à fait je trouve
une admissible de s'attaquer un jeune
qui est en plus si vous voulez par
alliance parent de du président mais en
quoi peut-il être responsable ou peut-on
lui reprocher le comportement l'attitude
les déclarations les décisions de Macron
et de d'utiliser la violence pour
contester quoi que ce soit c'est
certainement pas la bonne forme oui je
désapprouve totalement comment vous
expliquer ce climat de violence qu'on en
arrive là qui est responsable bah
écoutez la société a dérivé et je pense
que en face l'autorité n'a pas été
suffisamment
densifier pour répondre à la hauteur de
ces violences et plus
de toute manière c'est l'État qui est
l'exécutif l'État avec le gouvernement
bien le gouvernement confondu oui oui
absolument la dérive n'est pas que que
de ces quelques dernières années elle
est depuis 20 à 25 ans et c'est vrai que
tout le monde est responsable on ne peut
pas laisser se commettre ce type de
violence d'une part et puis ces
agressions regardé il y a plus de de
près de 2000 agressions sur les élus
rappelez-vous le maire de cygnes qui a
été tué parce qu'il voulait empêcher un
déversement de déchets et justement
puisque vous vous parlez des maires dont
les agressions se multiplient vous
l'avez dit le Sénat reçoit aujourd'hui
le maire de Saint-Brévin qui a
démissionné après des menaces et un
incendie de son domicile est-ce qu'il
faut renforcer les sanctions encore
renforcer les sanctions envers les
agresseurs d'élus oui effectivement on
entend dans la commission des lois
d'ailleurs
dans laquelle je siège on entend le
maire de Saint-Brévin sous le signe
les communes et l'avenir du maire
effectivement il faut non seulement
renforcer mais il faut je crois être
extrêmement sévère et la réponse doit
être immédiate car la majorité des élus
sont les manations du peuple et il
s'investit pour des tâches nobles donc
qui subissent des violences des
agressions comme de plus en plus on le
voit c'est inadmissible intolérable et
je crois qu'il faut il faut légiférer
très rapidement et il faut que la
justice sanctionne dans l'immédiat
d'ailleurs parce que c'est souvent trop
long donc les deux il faut il faut une
nouvelle loi et c'est pas uniquement un
problème de justice qui n'applique pas
renforcer les sanctions d'une part et il
faut d'autre part que la justice
effectivement applique rapidement la
sanction
un autre sujet c'était Isabelle borne on
l'a vu qui a commencé ses consultations
avec les syndicats pour l'après réformes
des retraites même si les syndicats ne
veulent pas tourner la page et Laurent
Berger qui était reçu hier soir a dit
empêché l'examen du texte d'abrogation
donc le texte de liotte comme le prévoit
la majorité serait inacceptable ce sont
les mots de la CFDT vous êtes d'accord
avec lui
écoutez je suis pas d'accord avec les
syndicats mais je comprends qu'il reste
sur une position puisqu'ils l'ont
défendu depuis les débuts mais est-ce
que la vraie question c'est est-ce que
c'est est-ce qu'il fallait une réforme
des retraites oui elle était
indispensable je l'ai voté nous l'avons
voté et je crois que il faut peut-être
l'améliorer il faut intégrer peut-être
la capitalisation mais on ne peut pas
rester dans cet état nous sommes les
seuls pays en Europe où nous travaillons
si peu d'une part on a un système de
retraite qui quelque part est basé sur
la solidarité et donc forcément il y a
de moins en moins de travailleurs et de
plus en plus de gens qui prétendent à la
retraite mais alors du coup est-ce que
la majorité présidentielle doit tout
faire pour empêcher l'examen de cette
proposition de loi d'abondance
au Parlement pas du tout je pense qu'il
faut l'examiner il faut aller au bout il
faut aller au vote il faut oui il faut
aller
oui quelle coupe struction que ce soit
dans un parlement dans une des chambres
que ce soit au Sénat ou à l'Assemblée
nationale et néfastes on l'a vu
d'ailleurs puisque le l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas pu examiner la loi sur
les retraites
à l'Assemblée vous dites ben allons
jusqu'au bout et votez à l'Assemblée
elle viendra au Sénat et nous on veut
c'est quoi ce moment-là on la votera pas
en tout cas le groupe LR de la votera
pas
on a appris hier que 14 personnes
allaient être jugée pour l'assassinat du
professeur pour vous des zones d'ombres
persistent sur cette assassinat que vous
souhaitez éclairer avant d'en parler
avec vous Henri le roi on va faire le
point sur tout ça avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Steve Jourdain qui nous
rejoint
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur le sénateur et si bon
on va d'abord faire le
point terre de la faire sa belle
l'enquête est finie place maintenant au
procès les juges d'instruction au
tranchées 14 personnes vont être jugées
pour leur implication dans l'assassinat
du prof d'histoire-géo décapité par un
islamiste les magistrats retenus
l'infraction de complicité d'assassinats
terroristes pour deux d'entre eux azymes
Boudaoud deux individus qui ont
accompagné le terroriste à Boulard
hanzorov pour acheter un couteau le
second célèbre rendu avec lui jusqu'au
collège de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine il
risque tous les deux la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité le terroriste
lui ne sera pas jugé en se rappelle il a
été tué juste après son crime plusieurs
zones d'ombre existe toujours oui que
s'est-il passé pendant 11 jours 11 jours
entre la diffusion des caricatures de
Charlie Hebdo par Samuel Paty et le
vendredi 16 octobre 2020 date de son
assassinat c'était l'objet de l'enquête
de la police qui a pris fin cet automne
mais des questions demeure y a-t-il eu
des défaillances au plus haut niveau
c'est ce que pense la famille de Samuel
Paty qui a porté plainte contre l'État
pour non-assistance à personne en péril
les ministères de l'Intérieur et de
l'éducation nationale sont notamment
dans le viseur de la famille une enquête
est ouverte à ce sujet depuis l'année
dernière ce qui est sur c'est que Samuel
Paty se savait traquer il avait écrit un
mail à ses collègues en expliquant qu'il
était menacé par des islamistes locaux
il avait demandé à ce qu'on leur
accompagne en voiture après les cours il
avait fait des recherches d'avocats
pénalistes sur internet ils se baladait
avec un marteau dans son sac bref Samuel
Paty a vécu ces derniers jours dans la
terreur la question est maintenant de
savoir si l'administration a commis une
faute en de la protégeant pas
suffisamment rien et un livre paru
récemment point de certains éléments à
charge contre l'État oui le journaliste
est producteur Stephen Simon a publié
une enquête sur les derniers jours de
Samuel Paty le point notamment la
minimisation du danger par le
renseignement territorial les services
départementaux les Yvelines avaient été
informées de la menace qui pesait sur
l'enseignant le commissariat de Conflans
avait lui aussi été mis au courant
plusieurs signalements avait été émis
par la plateforme farose contre le futur
terroriste Stéphane Simon considère
enfin que la DGSI n'a pas été à la
hauteur monsieur le sénateur est-ce
qu'il y a eu défaillances des services
de l'État écouter il m'appartient pas de
juger s'il y a eu défaillances mais vous
avez raison vous auriez très bien résumé
l'affaire et quand on lit le livre de
Stéphane Simon les derniers jours de
Samuel Patty effectivement on peut se
poser des questions et c'est vrai que
c'est la raison qui m'a amené à demander
une commission d'enquête effectivement
il y a comme vous l'avez dit très
justement 14 personnes dont si mineur
qui sont renvoyés par la justice
l'affaire et entre les mains de la
justice mais il appartient je dirais au
Parlement de créer une commission
d'enquête c'est ce que j'ai fait en
demandant en envoyant ma demande au
président du Sénat et à la commission
des lois pour cette
examen et on verra dans le temps mais
c'est vrai que ce livre mais en évidence
les des zones sur les signalements et
les alertes concernant l'islamisme
radical autour de l'établissement
scolaire d'une part ensuite quelles ont
été les mesures prises pour les
autorités pour prêter l'enseignement et
sa famille j'ai si vous voulez soulever
et on a plus 6 qui ont été payé ma
demande de commission d'enquête et c'est
pas parce que il y a le ministre de la
Justice a écrit au président du Sénat
pour dire mais la justice est saisie il
appartient maintenant à la justice
d'aller au bout de sa démarche
ne peut pas empiéter sur les
problématiques de la justice absolument
mais rappelez-vous l'affaire Benalla
j'ai siégé j'étais commissaire justement
dans cette commission d'enquête sur
l'affaire Benalla il y avait elle a été
traduite en justice et nous avons au
Sénat effectivement éclairer les zones
d'ombres qui persistaient afin de
prendre et de proposer des mesures c'est
ce que je demande pour l'affaire de
Samuel Paty tout simplement on peut dire
que c'est malpathie a été aband par
l'état où c'est trop on peut pas dire
sincèrement moi j'ai lu ce livre qui se
lit en trois ou quatre heures avec des
précisions et des zones d'ombres qui
sont évidentes est-ce qu'il a été
abandonné je ne dirai pas abandonner
mais est-ce qu'il a été laissé sans
protection certainement est-ce qu'on
aurait pu le soustraire en tout cas à
l'ambiance puisque les 10 derniers jours
sont décrits dans ce livre et
honnêtement et sincèrement je ne
comprends pas comment on a pu laisser
Samuel Paty dans son collège sans le bip
pour rentrer dans le collège vous rendez
compte et avec les menaces qu'il avait
des islamistes connus et reconnus des
intégristes qui avaient déjà eu affaire
à la justice et il s'est retrouvé
assorti de à la sortie de son de son
établissement avec un intégriste et un
islamiste qui la poignardée de plusieurs
coups de couteau il avait son marteau
comme vous l'avez dit il a même pas pu
se défendre personne ne le protégeait il
y a quand même une interrogation que
l'on peut légitimement se poser surtout
quand on est parlementaire et je crois
que la commission d'enquête si elle est
retenue fera certainement la clarté sur
ces zones d'ombres vous avez un espoir
quand même qu'elle soit écoutez la seule
je crois le seul obstacle ce serait
d'invoquer l'affaire en justice qui
vient effectivement d'aboutir à 14
inculpations et mise en examen pardon
avec l'ancien terme dans si mineur
quelles sont les personnes que vous
souhaitez interroger très précisément la
DGSI par exemple mais pas que la digesté
la DGSI
les vous savez que dans cette affaire
tous les protagonistes du côté de
l'éducation nationale ont été
récompensés décorés muter avec promotion
et je ne comprends pas comment
on peut laisser un individu qui est
menacé dont l'épreuve ont été établies
sans protection on voulait entendre
Jean-Michel Blanquer que ce soit clair
fera partie s'il y a une commission
d'enquête certainement que Jean-Michel
branque bancaire fera partie des gens en
temps je vous rappelle que dans une
commission d'enquête parlementaire les
gens déposent sous serment donc son
convoqués dépose sous serment et
l'ensemble des éléments seront rapportés
dans un rapport de la commission
d'enquête avec des préconisations pour
moi et pour nous je crois lecteur de ou
spectateurs de de cette affaire qui va
se dérouler au niveau du procès et bien
on doit avoir les éléments pour pouvoir
apprécier si Samuel Paty a été abandonné
et c'est vrai que la famille a porté
plainte et vous l'avez dit très
justement pour non-assistance à personne
en danger le collège dans lequel
enseignait Samuel Paty ne porte toujours
pas son nom contrairement à la promesse
qui avait été faite lorsqu'il a été
assassiné comme on l'expliquait bon
écoutez par la peur par la crainte parce
que notre pays rentre dans un dans une
période où on a peur de faire les choses
rappelez-vous
quand on a voulu baptiser des collèges
de noms de gens qui ont été assassinés
et bien les parents d'élèves les
enseignants tout le monde a peur et
c'est pour ça que le collège de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine ne porte pas le
nom de Samuel Paty parce que les gens
ont peur des représailles ont peur de
nouvelles agressions vis-à-vis du
collège des enseignants des parents et
des et des
scolarisés donc c'est quoi c'est déjà
une victoire des islamistes
écoutez en tout cas
ces preuves que quelque part on n'a pas
le courage d'aller au bout c'est vrai
que c'est un enseignant qui était
distingué qui a été reconnu comme étant
de grande qualité de la moindre des
choses ce serait de donner le nom de ce
collège Samuel Paty
elle a affaire Patty a été créée en fond
justement pour le Deluxe contre le
séparatisme mais le Sénat enquête sur
les conditions d'attribution de ce fond
les travaux ont débuté hier la gauche
parle de scandale des Tavaux aussi oui
absolument écoutez c'est vrai que
Marlène CAPA a créé ce fond de 2
millions et demi aujourd'hui vous avez
deux associations c'est en tout cas le
parquet national financier ouvert une
enquête
des de vos confrères ont été sur le
sujet que ce soit France 2 ou Marianne
et puis dernièrement un média en ligne
aussi à apporter un certain nombre qui
vont alimenter la commission d'enquête
et je fais tout à fait confiance à cette
commission d'enquête qui comme vous
l'avez dit a commencé hier merci
justement on parle à tout à l'heure du
fond Marianne ce sera à suivre dans le
club on va aller voir l'actualité des
Alpes-Maritimes maintenant on va Nice on
retrouve Denis carro bonjour Denis merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous Denis
directeur des rédactions du groupe
Nice-Matin et Denis avec vous on revient
sur le projet de création d'un centre de
rétention administrative près de Nicée
le moins que l'on plaisir c'est que ce
projet ne fait pas l'unanimité
oui alors on le sait les Alpes-Maritimes
sont première ligne face à la à la crise
migratoire le député les républicains et
présidents des républicains
eriki par le même d'un véritable
raz-de-marée à la frontière avec
l'Italie une situation qui se traduit
notamment par l'entrée d'un nombre très
important et de plus en plus important
de mineurs étrangers isolés des mineurs
que le Conseil Départemental des
Alpes-Maritimes est chargé d'accueillir
mais ce qu'il n'arrive pas à faire étant
débordés par la flux l'afflux do mineur
alors face à cette pression migratoire
constante Elisabeth borne a annoncé il y
a un mois le renfort de 150 policiers
gendarmes à la frontière avec l'Italie
ces gendarmes et ses policiers ils sont
déployés et lundi dans un courrier
adressé au maire de Nice Christian
Estrosi le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin a marqué sa volonté de
créer dans une commune de la métropole
niçoise la Trinité
un centre de rétention administré
administrative de 100 places pour
accueillir les gens qui entrent
illégalement sur le territoire alors
cette décision à la provoqué la colère
du maire Ladislas Polsky il a lancé hier
une pétition et il explique qu'il fera
tout pour s'opposer à ce à ce projet
alors ma question au sénateur Henri
Leroy est-ce que Gérald de darmana a
raison de vouloir installer ce centre de
rétentieux administratif à la Trinité à
côté de Nice et une deuxième question
est-ce que face à cette crise migratoire
la réponse de l'État est adapté et
suffisante
alors bonjour monsieur Caro est-ce qu'il
faut installer un centre de rétention
administratif dans les Alpes-Maritimes
et notamment le plus proche de la
frontière oui vraisemblablement je crois
que les tractations ont eu lieu avec le
maire de Nice en fait il a été proposé
un terrain donc la ville de Nice est
propriétaire à la Trinité je comprends
parfaitement le maire de la Trinité qui
se révolte contre ça puisque
constitutionnellement un maire peut
aménager son territoire en respectant la
loi bien sûr comme bon lui semble or si
la demande émane vraisemblablement du
maire de Nice est-ce que il faut
installer pour votre première question
oui effectivement je pense que c'est
indispensable vous avez raison de dire
sa véritable raz-de-marée Éric Ciotti
n'exagère pas en disant ça il suffit de
se rendre sur le terrain comme vous êtes
un homme de terrain vous avez dû y aller
vous avez dû envoyer des journalistes
effectivement c'est très préoccupant les
renforts de l'État la réponse a été il y
a des et des gendarmes mobiles qui sont
arrivés effectivement par le biais du
ministère de l'Intérieur est-ce que
l'État fait ce qu'il faut pas
suffisamment en tout cas pour enrayer
sur raz-de-marée parce que ça a été
multiplié c'est aujourd'hui venant de la
Méditerranée c'est 300 % de plus que
l'année dernière mais il y a aussi des
chiffres je redonne la parole à Denis
après mais des chiffres qu'on va donner
depuis le 1er janvier 9737 étrangers en
situation irrégulière on fait l'objet
d'une procédure de non-admission à la
frontière franco-italienne c'est un
tiers de plus que l'an dernier il y a eu
également 70% d’étrangers interpellés
ailleurs dans votre département en plus
que l'an dernier et concernant les
mineurs non accompagnés là aussi ça a
doublé
est-ce que ça veut dire que le
gouvernement fait preuve d'une politique
efficace en matière d'immigration
écoutez je crois que la politique
d'immigration n'est pas efficace la
preuve puisque les Alpes-Maritimes sont
devenus une vraie passoire
on va sécher ça parce que la politique
est efficace écoutez honnêtement et
sincèrement je pense que la loi n'est
pas adaptée face à l'envahissement
puisque dernièrement je crois que
Nice-Matin d'ailleurs monsieur Carola la
signalé l'un des des immigrés à menacer
les forces de sicilien on leur disant on
reviendra on vous envahira donc est-ce
que l'État fait ce qu'il faut pour
enrayer cette vague d'immigration non
manifestement il faut changer la loi il
faut un projet de loi nous allons
d'ailleurs
le faire il m'appartient pas de le
détailler mais je pense que
Eric Chiotti le fera très prochainement
on va déposer une loi ordinaire une
séquence un prochainement bah écoutez la
semaine prochaine la semaine prochaine
il y aura un projet de loi
constitutionnel parce qu'il faut changer
la constitution parce que
l'administration si vous voulez retoque
il y a aucune politique migratoire qui
correspond à la situation qui pourrait
être menée si on ne change pas la
Constitution
actuellement ce sont les conseils
départementaux qui sont chargés de
l'accueil des mineurs étrangers isolés
on voit toute la difficulté dans les
Alpes-Maritimes ou à certains moments le
problème est tellement et tellement
présent qu'on doit réquisitionner là un
hôtel à un gymnase est-ce que les
départements doivent continuer à assumer
ou est-ce que l'État doit davantage les
les épaules écoutez vous parlez des
Alpes-Maritimes mais il se il se trouve
que j'ai fait partie d'une commission
d'enquête aussi sur les mineurs non
accompagnés où j'ai été aux quatre coins
de France avec d'autres sénateurs et on
se rend compte que l'État effectivement
ne répond pas à la demande et aux
besoins des départements parce que toute
la charge financière et pour les
départements et l'État n'aligne pas si
vous voulez les chiffres par rapport aux
besoins exprimés aux besoins ressentis
sur le terrain non je pense que l'État a
une politique vis-à -vis des mineurs non
accompagnés qui n'est pas à la hauteur
des besoins est-ce que Gérald Darmanin a
eu raison de dire que Georgia Meloni la
première ministre italienne était
incapable de régler les problèmes
migratoires politiques est-ce qu'il a
est-ce que il peut critiquer
je dirais un autre état sur la politique
migration alors que nous-mêmes nous ne
sommes pas en mesure je dirais de de
donner des leçons
Denis vous avez eu une autre question on
regarde une de Nice Matin
on peut regarder la Une de Nice ce matin
avec avec une info une annonce hier
Emmanuel Macron qui a annoncé que la
création d'un Institut hospitalo
universitaire
à Nice ça sera un pôle d'excellence
spécialisé dans les dans les maladies
respiratoires et ça confirme
l'excellence de la recherche sur la Côte
d'Azur et dans les Alpes-Maritimes
elle a une de l'édition de Nice-Matin
merci Denis carro merci infiniment
d'avoir été avec nous depuis vos studios
de Nice on va terminer en parlant des
républicains
on va terminer en parlant des
républicains puisqu'on était dans les
Alpes-Maritimes le nombre d'adhérents
des républicains dans les
Alpes-Maritimes étant très forte baisse
comment vous l'expliquer
bah écoutez je crois que
il n'y a pas que les républicains les
gens s'intéressent de moins en moins à
la politique qui devient de moins en
moins intéressante d'ailleurs
je crois que l'interview de de Laurent
Wauquiez et significatif sur le
désintérêt complet de la majorité des
Français de la politique
dans le dans le point il dit que il faut
vraiment tout changer il faut vraiment
évoluer il faut reprendre le pouvoir les
politiques doivent reprendre le pouvoir
faire ce qu'ils disent ils disent qu'ils
font et ne pas laisser les
administrations sanctionner
systématiquement les représentants du
club que sont les politiques mais là
alors le nombre d'adhérents baisse dans
les Alpes-Maritimes alors que c'est Rick
cioti qui a pris la tête du parti un
enfant des Alpes-Maritimes est-ce que
Éric Ciotti échoue à reconstruire le
parti à rassembler est-ce qu'il a un
problème d'autorité et de leadership euh
non je ne le pense pas écoutez moi je
connais Eric Ciotti depuis 30 ans hier
nous avons avez un bureau politique je
crois qu'il faut lui laisser autant il y
a eu les réformes des retraites que vous
avez vu qu'il y a
occupé constamment la scène politique et
qui a été catastrophique pour les
républicains et qui non n'a pas été
catastrophique pour les rebelins on se
sent que
oui il y a une division parce que il y a
certains députés qui ont joué personnel
et pour ne pas le citer Pradier a été
vraiment le le petit le petit cafard
dans dans cette affaire parce qu'en
réalité avant et là a raison Emmanuel
Macron quand il dit les gens se sont
débiles ça s'adresse à Pradier parce
qu'en réalité Pradier était pour la
retraite à 65 ans avant que si vous
voulez le peuple s'enflamme pour dire
non on ne veut pas travailler 2 ans de
plus mais non
eric est en train va relancer
bah écoutez il lui a enlevé sa place de
de
je pense que ça suffit il a pas à
l'exclure Pradier de répartir il n'est
plus d'accord avec sa famille n'est plus
d'accord avec les décisions qui sont
prises mais qui s'en aille pourquoi
reste-t-il chez les républicains il peut
aller chez les indépendants en tout cas
pour répondre à votre question
concrètement il y aura une relance bien
sûr des additions on est dans le creux
de la vague je pense que
forcément on est au mois de mai d'ici la
rentrée de de septembre on aura une
vague d'adhésion une vague de je dirais
d'appel au renouvellement des additions
merci Henri le roi merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure